herzlich willkommen zu einem zdf heute
live im grunde genommen könnte man sagen
grund zum jubeln gestern eine neue
rekordzahl noch nie sind so viele
menschen in deutschland geimpft worden
gegen korona mehr als 700.000 deutsche
aber ist es wirklich grund zum jubeln
die intensivmediziner schlagen nämlich
gleichzeitig heute alarm die zahl der
betten die auf deutsche
intensivstationen belegt sind mit 19
patienten steigt rasant an heute sind es
mehr als 4.500 und täglich kommen so
viele neue coop 19 patienten hinzu dass
ein fachmann per twitter offen die
politik fragt ich zitiere liebe
entscheidungsträger wie hoch sollen die
zahlen dennoch steigen bevor ihr
reagieren wollte und tatsächlich es tut
sich was nach wochen und monaten in
denen bund und länder konferenzen quasi
ergebnislos waren weil am ende die
länder doch gemacht haben was sie
wollten nachdem die kanzlerin vor
einigen wochen gesagt hat so kann es
nicht weitergehen zieht jetzt doch die
bundesregierung offenbar mehr macht an
sich versucht es die bund länder
konferenz also kanzlerin und
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidentin am montag ist
geplatzt stattdessen soll in windeseile
ein neues infektionsschutzgesetz
verabschiedet werden damit der bund mehr
vollmachten hat um zu entscheiden wie es
zwischen sylt und berchtesgaden
weitergehen soll bei einer sieben tage
incidents über 100 wie ernst ist die
lage was muss getan werden was kann
getan werden viele fragen stellen sich
dabei auch juristische deshalb ist im
studio bei mir auch mein zdf
rechtsexperte kollege felix zimmermann
schön dass du da bin und wir können
sprechen mit professor uwe janssens
ehemals der chef bis vor kurzem der chef
der divi der deutschen
interdisziplinären vereinigung für
intensiv und notfallmedizin
schön dass sie für uns zeit haben guten
abend ja guten abend hallo und wir
begrüßen auch in der runde der in den
spd-gesundheitsexperten karl lauterbach
vielen dank dass sie auch mit dabei sind
heute morgen erläuterte
gesundheitsminister sparen und der chef
des robert koch-instituts wiler die lage
dabei erklärte sparen
es brauche einen harten lockdown einige
ministerpräsidenten hätten offenbar den
ernst der lage nicht erkannt wie ist die
lage
hier sind die zahlen woche eins nach
ostern und die korona lage ist
unübersichtlich denn die
infektionszahlen die von aktuell noch
keine antworten auf die vielen offenen
fragen und hätten nur wenig aussagekraft
warnt das robert koch institut die
fallzahlen und auch die sieben tages
inzidenz sind im moment nicht so
zuverlässig wie wir es gerne hätten das
liegt hauptsächlich daran weil über die
feiertage und auch die osterferien
weniger arztbesuche stattfanden und
entsprechend auch weniger getestet wurde
seit gestern registrierte das
robert-koch-institut 25 1464
neuinfektionen
296 menschen sind in verbindung mit
cupid 19 gestorben
die sieben tage incidents liegt bei
110,4 beim blick auf die zahlen der
letzten fünfzehn tage aber wird deutlich
dass der übliche zweitägige einbruch an
den wochenenden über ostern auf ganze
vier tage angestiegen ist grund dafür
sei neben den tests auch die personelle
besetzung der gesundheitsämter an den
feiertagen
ob die dritte welle also weiter rollt
wie vor den osterfeiertagen das werde
sich wohl erst mitte april zeigen
doch die intensivstationen schlagen
bereits jetzt alarm denn dort ist die
zahl der koma patientin wieder stark
gestiegen aktuell müssen rund 4500
menschen mit einer cupid 19 erkrankungen
intensivmedizinisch betreut werden ein
anstieg von 6 162 patienten innerhalb
einer woche
betroffen sind mittlerweile auch
vermehrt jüngere patienten sie sind oft
väter halten länger durch und haben
daher im schnitt einen längeren
aufenthalt auf den stationen mehr
patienten mehrbelastung die hilferufe
vieler mediziner werden lauter
also wir haben es gerade gesehen gehört
in den letzten tagen ist die zahl der
neuinfektionen leicht gesunken aber das
lag wohl an ostern weniger tests
natürlich weniger meldungen von
gesundheitsämtern also überhaupt keinen
grund zur entwarnung sagt der chef des
rk ii nun haben wir sie hier professor
jahns und sie kennen bestens die
situation auf den intensivstationen wie
dramatisch ist denn die lage die lage
ist im augenblick völlig im griff sie
würde aber dramatisch werden wenn das so
weitergeht und deshalb sind seit wochen
eigentlich damit beschäftigt unsere
warnende stimme zu erheben wir haben
ganz klar darauf hingewiesen wir haben
ein gutes modell
was genau exakt vorhergesagt hat was
jetzt passiert ist und wir haben schon
vor wochen vor der vorletzten mpk
konstanz gesagt wir brauchen einen
durchgreifen lockdown damit die
impfungen endlich greifen können und wir
müssen ganz runter von diesen
infektionszahlen herr lauterbach wird
das mit sicherheit gleich nochmals
wissenschaftler bestätigen damit wir
wirklich endlich aus diesen zahlen
herauskommen wir sehen das jetzt in
tübingen wir sehen es im saarland dass
eine öffnung die angesichts dieser
epidemiologische lage ein völker ich
würde fast sagen wahnsinn ist und sich
als irrtum erweist nun sagen natürlich
die verantwortlichen dort ein
ministerpräsident tanz im saarland ja
das ist aber doch mit tests
abgesichertes ist ein modellversuch was
sagt der mediziner
ja die testverfahren um das noch einmal
ganz klar zu sagen wir haben ihre
wirkliche wirksamkeit in einer in einer
epidemiologischen situation wo wir nicht
so hohe infektionszahlen haben denn wir
wissen mittlerweile aus sehr guten
wissenschaften analysen dass diese
antigene schnell dass ihre schwächen
haben wir haben viele falsch negative
ergebnisse das heißt es werden patienten
menschen negative presse die eigentlich
positiv sind und dass in einer solchen
situation trägt dazu bei dass der virus
der auch insofern ansteckender ist die
b17 mutante sich weiter in der
bevölkerung verbreiten kann
die konzepte prinzipiell sind gut wenn
die impfungen da sind wenn wir eine
kontrolle über das infektionsgeschehen
haben und dann wirklich konsequent in
wichtigen bereichen schulen etc durch
testen aber in nordrhein westfalen
achten die schulen ja glaub ich noch bis
zum heutigen tag darauf dass sie
irgendwelche testverfahren bekommen also
alles gut gemeint aber vielleicht der
umsetzung noch ein bisschen holprig
deshalb müssen jetzt wahrscheinlich
andere maßnahmen gezogen werden und
deshalb jetzt nimmt berlin offen sich
das heft in die hand
ihr nachfolger der jetzige präsident der
die wie gern und mag sagte heute es
brennt ich zitiere die lage ist sehr
dramatisch jeder tag zählt wo werden wir
den landen in ein zwei drei vier fünf
wochen
wenn sich jetzt nichts dramatisches tut
das was sie ja gefordert haben nehmen
wir doch den heutigen tag 25.000
neuinfektionen wir wissen und das sind
belastbare daten wir wissen dass von 100
saß kopf zwei infizierten personen 1,4
bis drei personen im weiteren verlauf
auf einer intensivstation landen
das würde bei 25.000 infektionen nur am
heutigen tage bedeuten dass wir in zehn
bis 14 tagen
350 bis 750 personen mit 19 auf einer
intensivstation in deutschland behandeln
müssen neben wir drei tagen vier tagen
hintereinander solche instanzen null
komma nichts bei 2 3000 zusätzlichen co
mit 19 patienten und wir sind in der
verzögerung wir laufen hinterher und das
wollen wir nicht und das hat der kollege
max auch mit gemeint da wollen wir nicht
hin und das wollen wir den patienten
nicht zumuten denn die haben wenn die
auf eine intensivstation sterben kommen
ein sterberisiko von 50 prozent und die
belastung für die mitarbeiter die möchte
am ende noch einen die erreicht jetzt
ein maß wo wir sorge haben dass die uns
wegbrechen und dann haben wir noch nicht
mal helfende hände die uns unterstützen
im kampf gegen die schweren
infektionskrankheit
der virologe drosten an der charité in
berlin hat das was sie jetzt gesagt
haben gehört und hat getwittert das was
die intensivmediziner sagen ist ein
notruf und diesen notruf aus den
intensivstationen wollen wir uns einfach
im film kurz angucken
was wenn man hilfe braucht und im
krankenhaus ist kein intensiv bett mehr
frei
erste städte wie köln bonn und bremen
melden dass sie kaum noch kapazitäten
haben wie schon im dezember
damals mussten intensiv patientinnen auf
krankenhäuser in andere regionen
verteilt werden
aktuell gibt es in deutschland weniger
als 3000 freie intensivbetten pro
krankenhaus sind das noch 1,5 betten und
da müssen nicht nur mit 19 patienten
versorgen sondern jeden herz und hat
jeden schlaganfall jeden akuten bauch
und das ist wirklich wirklich knapp
normalerweise sagt man hat eine
80-prozentige auslastung um um
handlungsfähig zu sein
das haben wir schon lange verlassen nach
ostern sind die infektionszahlen
zunächst gesunken
einige ministerpräsidenten hatten das
positiv interpretiert und sich gegen
einen lock down ausgesprochen
eine falsche einschätzung kritisiert der
chef des rk ii
dann kann es doch nicht sein dass man
sich durch einige niedrige zahl über
einige tage irritieren lässt sondern wir
sehen ja dass die zahlen wachsen und ich
will das noch mal sagen
der einzige wirkliche echtzeit indikator
den wir haben und da bin ich sehr
dankbar für das war das glaube ich im
april letzten jahres gesetzlich geregelt
haben
die intensivbetten register da brauchen
wir jetzt nicht drumherum zu reden oder
zu diskutieren
jens spahn fordert einen harten lockdown
um die dritte welle zu brechen und auch
um das klinikpersonal zu schützen wollen
wir warten bis 10.000 also was ist in
die logik wenn wir warten bis sie wollen
wir die grenzen austesten wollen wir es
einmal austesten was das land kann in
notsituationen in der intensivstation
jeder tag den wir später handeln
verlieren wir menschen leben ganz klar
die botschaft ist eindeutig eine antwort
der politik steht noch aus zur politik
und zu idel lauterbach kommen wir sofort
blitzschnell nur noch eine frage an den
mediziner weil wir jetzt gerade die
situation auf den intensivstationen
gesehen haben wenn wir gleichzeitig herr
professor jahns höher heute hören dass
es einen impf rekord gegeben hat das
gestern 719 1000 impfdosen verabreicht
worden sind so viele wie noch nie
könnte man dann sagen na ja es wird sich
doch besser durch das impfen und
insofern wird sich auch sehr schnell die
die situation auf den intensivstationen
verbessern also bis sich der imkerverein
stellt das heißt eine schwere kost 19
infektion verhindert wird nach der
ersten impfung braucht es seine zeit der
setzt zwar schon nach 16 bis 24 tagen
ein aber das reicht einfach nicht aus
die zeit haben nicht diese zeit müssen
wir alle einfach schon überbrücken aber
nichtsdestotrotz ich bleibe dabei das
ist natürlich ein wahnsinnig toller
erfolg tolle zahlen mit dem impfen aber
wir sind weit entfernt von einer
ausreichend durchimpfung der
risikopositionen in jenseits der
unterhalb der 80 jahre
die 50 bis 70 bis 80 er in die
begleiterkrankung haben die sind alle
noch nicht geben ist also wir sind davon
weit entfernt auf die impfung dürfen wir
uns zum jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht
verlassen wir müssen sie aber mit aller
macht voran treiben und ich sagte die
hausärzte müssen dazu das ist ein ganz
ganz wichtiger standbein das haben wir
doch jetzt gesehen haus es dazu sofort
geht das impf tempo nach vorne und das
ist doch eine gute botschaft
herr lauterbach die politik ist gefragt
das haben wir gerade im beitrag gehört
am 33 das ist mehr als ein monat her
wurde notbremse vereinbart wurden ja
regelungen ich habe hier die papiere
noch wir haben damals einen livestream
gemacht und der wurde genau dieses din
a4 blatts gezeigt welche maßnahmen
getroffen worden das wurde ja alles
verabschiedet und was muss denn jetzt
passieren warum ist das eigentlich
bisher hat das bisher nicht gegriffen
deshalb nicht gegriffen in der tat das
ist es viel zu wenig gemacht worden die
regelmäßig angewendet worden sind zum
teil unterlaufen worden durch alibi
hotel versuche wo man gesagt hat wir
versuchen jetzt lockerungen das hat ihn
zwar in sich das geschadet zum einen
diese hoffnungen haben unmittelbar
selbst dort wo gelockert wurde zu
infektionen geführt und zum zweiten
müssen doch das signal gegeben worden
der luft und ist sich wirklich so ernst
gemacht die politik mache das hier
augenzwinkern das kann gleich sagt schon
mit lockerungen begonnen werden in
modellversuchen somit war eine gemischte
botschaft da so an platz wir haben
tatsächlich die notlage in der wir
damals schon waren sie haben ja einfach
nicht ernst genug genommen
zumindest ist das auf kommunaler ebene
andere häufig zu gemacht worden und da
haben wir jetzt die konsequenzen vor der
brust das es gar dass die intensiv
kapazität kapazität in den nächsten
wochen komplett ausgetestet werden wird
wir werden wahrscheinlich an die grenzen
kommen
wir werden jetzt also verschärfte
maßnahmen beschließen müssen aber bis
sie wirklich graalmann bis sie wirklich
wirken also werden wahrscheinlich
intensiv dazu jetzt haben wir sie
stimmen dazu und sagen es hat am dritten
märz also vor über einem monat klare
beschlüsse gegeben die aber unterlaufen
worden sind sie sagen es gerade alibi
modellversuche et cetera
da könnte man ja sagen das was doch in
den letzten vier wochen diese alibi
versuche gebracht haben nämlich
steigende infektionszahlen das müsste
doch jeder gesehen haben nun hat aber
ihr parteikollege der niedersächsische
ministerpräsident weil erst gestern
erneut erklärt er sei gegen einen
bundesweiten locker und weil sich die
lage in niedersachsen ja entspanne
nun hat der chef des robert
koch-instituts wiler heute gesagt es
kann nicht sein dass man sich durch
niedrige zahlen über einige tage so
irritieren lässt hat damit ja indirekt
auch ein weil kritisiert wer hat denn
nun recht liegt weil völlig falsch ihr
parteikollege zunächst einmal ich gebe
hier niemandem noten ich sage nicht mehr
recht oder unrecht hat sondern ich sage
einfach wie ich die dinge sehe die also
zahlen die wir jetzt gesehen haben den
letzten tagen sind natürlich an
artefakte tatsache dass sowohl weniger
getestet wurde weil weniger leute zum
arzt gegangen sind über zuerst sind als
auch die aus der infektionen die beiden
aus besuchern stattgefunden also weiß
ich dass die sind weniger genau und
weniger häufig so weitergegeben worden
wir haben daher das was wir immer haben
den feiertagen artefakte wir haben
zahlen künstlich zu niedrig sind sie
sollte welle ist natürlich weiter
gegangen
das hat da keine also beeinflussung
gegeben es ist ja auch nichts passiert
was das hätte erreichen können somit
werden wir den nächsten tagen deutlich
steigende werte sehen und werden dann
sehen dass die dritte welle hat nicht
zum stoppen gekommen ist sie würde
überhaupt nicht stoppen ohne dass wir
seit ich dass wir die notbremse oder
nach london wechseln würden und die
maßnahmen dafür sind die heute aus dem
tisch gekommen
herr professor jan ist wir haben es eben
schon gehört die besorgten worte von rk
ii chef wiler der gesagt hat jeden tag
den wir nicht handeln verlieren wir
menschenleben haben wir es gerade gesagt
es ist viel geredet worden im bund
länder konferenzen schon vor wochen vor
monaten und herr lauterbach hat es
gerade auch noch mal beschrieben das
alibi modellversuche gegeben hat
lockerungen gegen sozusagen jeden
menschenverstand aus medizinischer sicht
wie sehen sie das ganze macht sie das
wütend ist das irgendwie auch ein
bisschen wahlkampf auf dem rücken der
des personals in den kliniken was ja nun
die erste welle die zweite welle und nun
in der dritten welle schuften muss ja
niemals personal erstmal zur seite
blicken wir doch auf den patienten ein
namhafter biologe hat in diesem jahr den
begriff stresstest der intensiv medizin
gebraucht das muss man sich mal auf der
zunge zergehen lassen ich habe das eben
ja schon erwähnt wenn einen sie als
patient mit einer kuh mit 19 erkrankung
auf eine deutsche intensivstation kommen
dann haben sie ein hohes sterberisiko ja
dann wissen sie dass sie wenn sie dann
noch beatmet werden zu 50 prozent diese
intensivstation nicht lebend verlassen
werden dann müssen wir über stress test
gar nicht mehr darüber reden hier geht
es tatsächlich um menschenleben das hat
herr wieder ganz klar und zu recht
betont
und da muss sich die gesellschaft und
auch die wirtschaft fragen lassen ist
uns das wert wollen wir das austesten
wollen wir das zulassen dass wir täglich
wieder neue wachsende
sterblichkeitsraten haben wir haben das
gesehen noch heute sind die zahlen die
todeszahlen gestiegen und 7 werden im
nachgang auch weiter steigen das wären
wir leben und das zweite die
mitarbeitenden auf den intensivstationen
die werden an der stelle ganz vergessen
das möchte ich nicht überhöhen aber die
leistung was sie machen müssen
mit diesen menschen zu arbeiten und
danach noch andere schwerkranke
patienten ohne kurve 19 das ist schon
eine leistung da ziehen wir den hut vor
und die dürfen wir doch nicht austesten
bedürfen auch nicht die leistung nach 14
monaten noch mal sagen wir gucken
jetzt einfach noch mal nach ob die das
dann aushalten das ist nicht fair
das ist auch unmoralisch und muss man so
auszudrücken
ja ich weiß nicht ob sie das waren oder
ihr kollege ich glaube jedenfalls einen
intensivmediziner sagte die große gefahr
ist natürlich dass nach der dritten
vierten welle auch wenn irgendwann mal
corona bekämpft ist uns ganz ganz ganz
ganz viele kolleginnen und kolleginnen
auf intensivstationen einfach von der
fahne gehen
die werden uns von der fahne gehen das
kann ganz klar sagen die signale sind
klar wir haben befragungen während der
krone pandemie im oktober durchgeführt
da haben uns die mitarbeiten die
pflegekräfte schon ganz klar
signalisiert gute befragung dass sie mit
den maßnahmen unzufrieden sind dass sich
allein gelassen fühlen dass sie keine
wertschätzung fühlen und dass sie auch
zu einem hohen prozentsatz darüber
nachdenken den beruf zu verlassen 36%
ich sage ihnen ganz ehrlich das ist ein
train ein verlust an an hoch
qualifizierten fachpersonal das können
wir uns nicht leisten und deshalb ein
weiter grund zu sagen wir müssen diese
stationen schützen menschen den schützen
ist das allerwichtigste
aber die mitarbeiten die müssen auch in
schutz genommen werden also ganz kurz
noch mal die frage an sie professor
janßens weil wir jetzt gleich über die
politik sprechen wir haben von ihnen
beiden ja gehört es tut sich langsam
etwas ist das sozusagen ein appell den
sie jetzt den politikern für die nächste
woche mit geben die bund länder
konferenz ist geplatzt stattdessen soll
das infektionsschutzgesetz und
verschärft werden sagen sie so zu sagen
das wird aber auch allerhöchste
eisenbahn doch sagen wir seit wochen
seit monaten und wir sind froh wenn dass
auf den weg gebracht wird umgesetzt wird
durchgreifen umgesetzt wird und auf alle
gleichzeitig eingesetzt wird ohne wenn
und aber und ohne diskussionen ohne 1000
interviews vorher nachher während wir
sind froh wenn es tatsächlich mal weiter
geht in einen ruhigen sommer rein und
ich bin mir sicher wir werden das
schaffen und ärzte märz und mitarbeitern
auf den intensivstationen wir werden das
schaffen aber es muss endlich eine linie
geben dann sind das klare worte von
ihnen herr professor jahns vielen vielen
dank
wir würden gerne noch mit ihnen weiter
reden aber aus zeitgründen wollen wir
das nicht überstrapazieren vielen vielen
dank dass sie mit dabei waren und wir
wollen natürlich jetzt über die
politischen aspekte weiterreden
bundeskanzlerin merkel hat
angekündigt das format bund länder
konferenz geht so nicht weiter
der bund müsse mehr das heft des
handelns an sich ziehen
schauen wir auf die man kann vielleicht
sagen heutige entmachtung der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
jetzt übernimmt es doch der bund zwei
tage telefonierten kanzlerin und
vizekanzler mit den ländern und das
kroner durcheinander der vergangenen
tage zu ordnen
es macht sind diese situation aufzulösen
durch eine klare regelung von der alle
wissen wie sie jetzt die nächste zeit in
der pandemie sein wird dann muss man
auch nicht alle zwei wochen darüber neu
verhandeln da muss auch nicht jeden tag
jemand ein neues interview geben um zu
verkünden was als nächstes zu tun ist
auch der bundestag wird damit stärker
eingebunden als bisher
das fordern abgeordnete und fraktionen
seit monaten
wir benötigen einen radikalen
wellenbrecher wir benötigten
einheitlichkeit und rechtssicherheit und
deswegen ist es gut und längst
überfällig dass der deutsche bundestag
mit dem bundesrat entscheidet alles was
zur senkung der zahlen führt was zur
entlastung der intensiv medizin führt
das werden wir mittragen aber das darf
auf gar keinen fall dazu führen dass die
eigentlichen aufgaben nämlich eine
beschleunigung beim impfen eine
verbesserung bei den tests dass das etwa
nicht geschieht werden tatsächlich schon
bei einer inzidenz von 100 neue
infektionen pro woche sogar über
ausgangssperren nachgedacht wird und er
alle modellprojekte um zum beispiel mit
tests handle oder außengastronomie zu
ermöglichen eingestellt werden
dann wäre das aus unserer sicht
unverhältnismäßig wenn die länder
tatsächlich mitmachen könnte die
gesetzesänderung schnell gehen wenn
charlotte war die frage an sie ist das
jetzt eine wirkliche wende in der korona
strategie auf die sie vielleicht auch
lange gewartet haben also wenn es in der
sache so kommt wie es notwendig ist also
werden der bundestag nicht nur zuständig
wird und jetzt eingesetzt macht sondern
in dem gesetz auf das richtige steht
nämlich das alter incidents über 100 die
notbremse gezogen wird und die
lockerungen die bis dahin also
beschlossen worden sind oder gleich zur
eröffnung geführt haben mich dann
zurückgenommen werden das dann
tatsächlich auch nicht unter dem alibi
eines modellversuches weitere
lockerungen gemacht werden dürfen und
stattdessen eine ausgangs schränke kommt
zum beispiel ab 20 uhr
also wenn der inhalt stimmt darauf kommt
es ja also es kommt darauf an nicht wer
beschließt und oder die entwickler
sondern was wird geschlossen wenn die
beschlüsse im inhalt stimmen dann kann
man damit arbeiten aber man muss ja
wirklich auch substanz drin sein
das würde bedeuten aber einer inzidenz
von 100 darf nicht auch nicht den
modellen gelockert werden und es muss
eine ausgangs beschränkung kommen war
die abendlichen termin eine große rolle
spielen
und es muss auch eine testpflicht in den
betrieben kommen wenn diese drei
komponenten in dem bundesgesetz darin
wären
und das wäre verbindlich geregelt dann
wäre das tatsächlich an wesentlicher
sprung nach vorne
wenn es aber nur ein bundesgesetz ist um
diese regeln stehen nicht drin sondern
lockere regelungen dann haben wir quasi
mit zitronen gehandelt
dann wird also an der situation die
nicht geklappt hat war die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz also die
beschlüsse nicht umsetzen können
sie wird dann ersetzt durch eine
bundestags beschloss lage die ebenfalls
nicht funktioniert weil wir uns im
bundestag auf diese strengen regeln also
werden wir sehr konzentriert und
gespannt darauf schauen was nächste
woche beschlossen wird es soll ja
dienstag erstmal durch das
bundeskabinett gehen und dann kommt es
eben in den bundestag dann werden wir
sozusagen gemeinsam da gespannt drauf
schauen aber das was heute geplant ist
ist ja durchaus eine spannende
rechtliche frage auch felix wie ist das
ganze rechtlich zu und gesehen ist das
eine entmachtung der länder die aber
sozusagen korrekt verläuft weil durch
abstimmung im bundestag
also herr schäuble gestern heute journal
gesagt man würde den ländern nur helfen
ja aber letztlich ist es natürlich
nichts anderes als eine entmachtung und
es sind sich auch das eine
bankrotterklärung der länder das sich
eben selbst nicht geschafft haben und
von oben quasi ein gesetz brauchen und
es ist ja nun wirklich tatsache dass
diese beschlüsse der mpk oft einfach
nicht umgesetzt wurden in
nordrhein-westfalen zum beispiel ist
wurden kontakt beschränkung vereinbart
und nordrhein westfalen hat man gesagt
ja gut aber das gilt nicht für zu hause
im privaten bereich wo er die ansteckung
am höchsten ist und so weiter und so
fort in hessen sind die kontakt
beschreibung nur eine empfehlung usw
da frage ich mich allerdings dann doch
denn es ist schon so dass der bundesrat
in irgendeiner weise eingebunden werden
muss
es kann ein zustimmungsgesetz seines
kanal einspruchsgesetz seien aber auch
beim einspruchsgesetz hat der bundesrat
die möglichkeit hier das hinauszuzögern
wenn er will
und da frage ich mich wenn die
bundesländer in der vergangenheit die
dinge nicht regeln wollten warum sollten
sie denn jetzt dann zustimmen dass der
bundestag durch ein gesetz das ganze
übernimmt das ist ja schon mal eine
frage warum hat es eigentlich tun sollte
finden wir nur eine begründung ein die
verantwortung wegschieben
dann waren es nicht wir dann war es eben
der bund das kann ja auch in diesen
zeiten vielleicht ganz angenehm sagen
dann wollen wir einfach sie direkt
fragen herr lauterbach
es ist die stellvertretende
regierungssprecherin gewesen die heute
gesagt hat bund und länder hätten sich
darauf geeinigt diesen weg zu gehen
nun muss ein neues verschärftes
infektionsschutzgesetz was das kabinett
wie gesagt am dienstag verabschieden
will in den bundestag und jetzt ist die
frage dann möglicherweise auch in den
bundesrat und das wäre die frage die er
felix gestellt hat die drängt sich ja
eigentlich auf wenn dann der bundesrat
die ländervertretung dann zustimmen dann
kann man sich doch nur fragen warum das
ganze nicht sozusagen schon wochen
vorher wenn man dann verschärften regeln
zustimmt ja weil es eben nicht möglich
war die länder auf einigen
seine linie zu bringen uns also wenn
jetzt einzelne länder mit so einem
bundestags bundesratsbeschluss besser
leben können indem sie eben bestimmte
freiheiten also waren der instanz über
100 auch was und dann nicht mehr haben
dann entlastet das natürlich die länder
auf dauer nicht ganz unrecht
und es kommt wie gesagt auf an was
drinsteht wenn das tatsächlich regeln
sind die greifen also aus wenn die
ausgangs beschränkung drinsteht wenn
klar darin steht dass die unternehmen
testen müssen und so wenn sie darin
steht dass es was es sind neue gesetz
nicht ausgehebelt werden kann unter dem
alibi von modell versucht man sich
locker ohren wenn also diese drei
kriterien erfüllt wären dann wäre das
natürlich ein wichtiger schritt nach
vorne
aber wenn nicht und uns noch nicht
funktionieren ich glaube nicht dass die
länder das blockieren können aus die das
hier auf zeit spielen können das ist
politisch nicht darstellbar
weil wir sind in einer notlage wir
wählen ja mitte der nächsten woche
werden wir deutlich steigende fallzahlen
sehen und also dann würden die länder ja
quasi erläutern müssen wieso hier nichts
passiert obwohl uns die fälle quasi ins
haus stehen
wir können ja sehen dass sie nach sehr
kurzer zeit wie jetzt eine situation
kommen wo es auch insbesondere sehr
viele kinder und eltern beträgt und die
also jahrgänge irgendwo und das
lebensorte 40 bis 60 betroffenen ist das
sind diejenigen die in den nächsten
wochen sehr schwer erkranken werden
diejenigen die dort risikofaktoren haben
aber nicht nur die
und das sind zum teil auch dann sehr
lange intensiv behandlungen die danach
so lanz schäden zur folge haben und in
beatmeten stellt die hälfte auf das
jüngere sind die antreffen wie überlebt
ist danach schwerst medizin nicht
gezeichnet wir haben es auch gesehen
dass von allen infizierten etwa 14%
übergehen in einer dauer erkrankung non
profit wo wir nicht wissen ob die
überhaupt wahrnehmen kann oder auch
überhaupt noch weiter zu bekommen ist
das scheint eine autoimmune genese zu
haben und den aldi ist da steht und die
länder blockieren dann ist das natürlich
nicht haltbar wurde
der druck sehr stark also zu nehmen und
dann wären wir auch ehrlich gesagt wenn
das jetzt tatsächlich dort hängen würde
dann kämen auch so dann gehen auch
diskussionen über staatsversagen aus
natürlich ich möchte aber nochmal einmal
den punkt von ihnen aufgreifen weil sie
sagten es darf dann keine modellversuche
mehr geben keine hintertürchen etc
das ist ja sozusagen ein bisschen kritik
und man sagen vielleicht auch an einen
ministerpräsidenten hans saarland ein
ganzes bundesland was zum test versuch
geöffnet hatte im saarland sind die
cafés offen etc
aber der ministerpräsident sagt dann
ebenso ein bisschen na ja wir mussten ja
auch öffnen wegen der gerichte etc felix
kannst du das ganze einordnen welche
rolle spielen denn am ende die gerichte
können sie am ende die gerichte die
judikative die dritte gewalt denn das
dann am ende wieder kassieren was jetzt
vielleicht bund und länder bundestag und
bundesrat verabschieden ja es ist er
ebenso haben natürlich immer den blick
erstmal auf die korona zahlen wie sind
die ten sie werden wie steigen die
zahlen die sagen wir die anderen effekte
dafür gibt's eben keine skala für die
kinder die vielleicht depressionen haben
für die ausgebliebene schulbildung da
gibt es keinen täglichen index gibt es
einfach nicht deswegen kann man ja auch
nicht zeigen und lauterbach sagt das ja
auch immer zu recht natürlich wenn wir
jetzt lange warten dann wird diese phase
dann aber noch vielleicht länger sein
der einschränkung weil die werte hoch
gehen doch die politik hat es ja eben
nicht geschafft innerhalb dieses jahres
dieses ursprüngliche modell hemmer und
dance stringent durchzuführen weiß ich
eben viele bundesländer nicht an die
maßnahmen auch gehalten haben und
deswegen müssten dann irgendwann die
gerichte an und sagen ihr das dauert
jetzt so lange wir ein bisschen
irgendwie auch öffnungen erlauben und
wenn wir jetzt die frage aufgreifen was
würden jetzt die gerichte tun wir haben
zum beispiel bei den ausgangs
beschränkungen schon auch gerichte
gehabt die gesagt tami das ist
unverhältnismäßig das ist zu weit
greifen und bewährte situation haben was
nicht mal vorstellen dass in einem
gesetz von norddeutschland bis
süddeutschland sollte was war es der
erste des gartens
alles die gleichen regeln gelten sollen
in einem gesetz das stell mir unheimlich
schwierig vor
da bleibt da überhaupt keinen raum für
ab schichtungen sondern wir schauen dass
das wäre jetzt die frage wir können ja
auch herr lauterbach sie und ich wir
sind nicht juristen und insofern ist das
manchmal schwierig für uns zu verstehen
aber ich habe ja auch in den letzten
wochen verstanden dass die gerichte
hinschauen auf die verhältnismäßigkeit
und dass man hinschaut und sagt hat
ihnen die politik nicht noch eine andere
möglichkeit so das aber mal die ausgangs
beschränkung durch eine andere maßnahme
vielleicht ersetzt werden kann und dann
kann die ausgangs beschränkung
vielleicht gekippt werden da sagt das
gericht ist nicht verhältnismäßig
insofern könnte ich jetzt als
nichtjurist ja vielleicht verstehen
bei einer inzidenz von 50 oder was auch
immer das gericht dann eben sagt da das
ist nicht verhältnismäßig da kann man
noch viele andere sachen machen aber das
was er jetzt gedacht das ist ja eine
ausgangs beschränkung von sylt des
berchtesgaden bei einer inzidenz von
über 100 das heißt also nur dann wenn
auf sylt genauso wie in berchtesgaden
die situation wirklich dramatisch ist
und keiner sagen kann die maßnahme
ausgangs beschränkung ist
unverhältnismäßig
wir beiden nichtjuristen denke mir das
gleiche lauter war ja das ist genauso
ist es ist ja so überall das gleiche
also wohl die 100 überschritten wird
die 100 überstellt
das ist nicht richtig wenn wir haben
jetzt zum beispiel gerichtsentscheidung
gehabt die gesagt haben selbst ist es
unzulässig aber im ganzen landkreis nur
auf die inzidenz zu gucken
denn selbst in einem landkreis kann es
ja bei der intelligenz abweichung geben
beispielsweise haben einen landkreis
gütersloh und da ist eine corona
hotspots ausgetreten einem pflegeheim
deswegen stellt die gesamte incidents
über 100 was aber eben nicht
gleichbedeutend ist mit der situation
dass im gesamten landkreis wirklich eine
höhere gefahr besteht und in der lehre
ist an sich ja auch ein problematischer
denn die inzidenz sagt ja noch nichts
zum beispiel über die belastung des
gesundheitssystems pc aus es kommt auch
darauf an wie er ist erkrankt sind es
eher jüngere sind es eher ältere
dh der wert der inzidenz ist ohnehin
schon ein schwieriger er hängt vom
testen ab und so weiter also dass in ein
gesetz zu passen ist sicherlich möglich
aber dann doch wieder auch
möglicherweise leichter angreifbar vor
verwaltungsgerichten mit dem unterschied
das ist dann nicht so einfach sein wird
eine ausgangs beschränkung für alle zu
kippen sondern da wird wahrscheinlich
eher der individuelle rechtsschutz
vorgehen dass einer sich gegen die
ausgangs beschränkung werden kann
aber nicht einer für alle klagen herr
lauterbach
da kommt contra von ihn ja nee das ist
also alles gut also ich bin ja mit
vielen dieser gerichtsurteil auf befasst
gewesen weil ich dann gebeten worden
behinderte stellung wir haben also
dagegen mit zu verfassen haus ausländer
perspektive oder was auch immer
und das wird auch weiter so sein es wird
auch immer wieder und wir wissen ja auch
dass die gerichte zu tat sehr
unterschiedlich aus so aufgestellt dass
wird immer wieder also gericht aufgeben
die also hier ihre eigenen
epidemiologischen überlegungen anstellen
geschichte die sich überlegen wie alt
sind die leute wie vielleicht sterben
darunter und und das konto das ist gut
dann sie also wie gesagt das ist ein
unabhängiger gewalt und das russland
stattfinden
das müssen wir in kauf nehmen aber das
also macht die regel die wir versuchen
umzusetzen nicht falsch sie ist
anwendbar und aus ich glaube dass die
meisten sich die großen gerichte
insbesondere die höheren instanzen
natürlich wo dann auch viel präziser
geprüft und gutachterlich vorgegangen
wird da werden diese also oder werden
diese ideen wenn sie gut begründet sind
werden wir natürlich obsiegen und also
in so einem gesetz steht ja auch nicht
denn die instanz ist alles aber also
wenn die inzidenz also hoch ist über 100
das ja keine hohe insel der sonderserie
incident dann geht es kurze zeit später
zur sache und zwar auch dann wenn also
die infizierten etwas jünger sind weil
wir ihm schon darauf hingewiesen wurde
wir sind ja in einer neuen situation mit
der mutation b17 kann man sagen ist also
50 das neue 60 und 60 ist das neue 70
die leute die menschen erkannten hat
sehr viel schwerer
daher ist auch das durchschnittsalter
derjenigen die auf der intensivstation
versorgt werden
total unter 50 jahre das sind ja auch
jüngere leute und das wird noch die
gerichte also zumindest in den höheren
instanzen wo dann auch bessere
gutachterliche informationen zur
verfügung liegt und wo man werde sich
der übergeordnete bedeutung der
rechtsprechung dann auch sehr bewusst
ist wird das natürlich wird das 1 1
also meine erfahrung ist er sich
unbedingt dass es für die höhere instanz
immer sorgfältig geprüft als die
darunter
und es ist ja auch das
oberverwaltungsgericht in lüneburg
gewesen was jetzt zuletzt die ausgangs
beschränkung dort gekippt hat also muss
die sorgfältige prüfung der nicht gerade
unbedingt bedeuten dass sie zugunsten
der regierungen zu gunsten der
einschränkung ausfällt man könnte auch
etwas was anderes vertreten und diese
richtung kommen wir sie beide ja
eigentlich zusammen herr lauterbach
nicht weil sie sagen es ist ein versuch
und letzten endes haben sie erfahrungen
mit gerichten gemacht und wie heißt es
so schön vor gott und auf hoher see
also muss man das ganze abwarten aber
noch eine spannende sache die er heute
auch deutlich geworden ist es geht jetzt
nicht nur darum dass sozusagen in einem
gesetz bundesweit von sylt bis
berchtesgaden geregelt ist ganz klar
wenn die institute über 100 ist dann
geht müssen im maßnahmen ergriffen
werden wie ausgangs beschränkungen
schließungen etc sondern der zweite
interessante punkte würden die incidence
über 200 ist dann sollen schulen und das
soll dann bundesweit auch wieder gelten
von flensburg bis zum bodensee
dann sollen die schulen wechseln in
distanz unterricht wenn das also auf
einmal zum ersten mal ein
zeitlich festgelegt würde dann wäre das
ja auch eine ich sag mal revolution weil
der bildungspolitik das was die schulen
machen tun sollen öffnen schließen ja
bisher ländersache war ist das so eine
art kleine revolution dass auf einmal
hier ein entscheidender punkt wo die
länder bisher gemacht haben was sie
wollen diesen den ländern genommen wird
also es ist auf jeden fall eine richtige
entscheidung mal also schulen zu
betreiben bei den über 200 wahnsinn in
derartigen zahlen
wir müssen davon ausgehen dass bei
infizierten kindern sieben prozent der
kinder in long profit über gehen noch
der grundlage neuer daten aus england wo
die beste statistik wie dem logische
erhebung also von sehr groß und
fallzahlen jetzt noch einmal
veröffentlicht worden ist so dass wir
also in den kindern nicht mehr wie
früher nur die also ich sage mal
infektionsgefahren für erwachsene daten
die dann schwer erkranken könnten sehen
dürfen sondern in der kantine selbst
sich die kinder entwickeln also zum teil
ebenfalls dass das chronische
erschöpfungssyndrom die mag ich ein
leopard ii das ist gar nicht gar nicht
das ist ein prozess im gehirn das sich
abspielt und wie sie kinder sind schwer
krank sind zum tag honig kann und dass
die schulden zu bezahlen waren der
inzidenz und 200 völlig unvertretbar und
wenn das auf diesem weg also hier
sichergestellt werden muss dann ist das
auf jeden fall epidemiologisch absolut
richtig ich hätte mir sogar gewöhnlich
man hätte noch stärker hier in die heute
noch niederländer war der schulpolitik
ein wissen weil gestern hat die
kultusministerkonferenz sich erneut
nicht einigen können war der unbedingt
zu beschließenden notwendigen doppelten
testung der schüler um an
präsenzunterricht teilnehmen zu können
man ist gestern erneut ohne ergebnis
auseinander gerade in einer so prekären
situationen wo viel wo so viel politik
in davon abhängt also wir müssen ja mit
b17 damit rechnen dass die große welle
die jetzt kommt in erster linie mal die
kinder und auch ihre
das sind ja die sache immer besonders
gefährdeten beiden profitiert und
gestern ist die kultusministerkonferenz
wieder gescheitert man hat sich nicht
auf einen entsprechenden beschluss
einigen können
das heißt dass der bund hier tatsächlich
zum schutz der kinder rechte ansicht sie
natürlich nur für die dauer der pandemie
das sind ja geliehener recht das ist ja
vorbei wenn die pandemie weg ist das ist
aus meiner sicht notwendig aber dann
auch noch mal eine frage dazu wenn wir
jetzt bei dem thema schulen sind der
nordrhein-westfälische ministerpräsident
laschet sagt sicherlich bei dem thema
abstandsgebot maske pflicht ausgangs und
kontakt beschränkungen das alles sollte
bundeseinheitlich geregelt werden
das würde aber sozusagen die regeln für
schulen und sozusagen in länder hand
lassen olaf scholz wiederum geht hin und
sagt nein
er befürwortet also diese diese idee
dass eben ab einer inzidenz von über 200
in wechsel unterricht gegangen wird gibt
es da dann doch wieder dissenz was das
thema schulen angeht
das kann gut sein dass es da ist gibt
dann muss aber bei jedem offen
gesprochen werden meine position ist
hier ganz klar unabhängig jetzt von der
frage wer was wir vorgeschlagen hat
sondern wir müssen sicherstellen dass
die schulen aber an der residenz von 202
besticht sind das eigentlich schon dann
wird er viel zu hoch ist und dass die
schule nur im präsenzunterricht
betrieben werden kann in der kombination
wechsel unter richtungswahl testen pro
woche der schüler die kinder die da
nicht mitmachen können weil die eltern
ist nicht wollen müssen ein anrecht
haben auf homeschooling kölner waren
präsenzunterricht nicht gar nehmen war
niemand da dann recht also seine durch
seine eigenen kinder die gesundheit der
anderen kinder in zu gefährden und auch
den unterricht über was zu gefährden die
man sich lange damit warten desto
schlimmer wird alles wir können hier
nicht hoffen dass die schulen gut
durchkommen sondern von allem was wir
wissen sind die schulen demnächst
wirklich groß ports felix frage eben an
dich das ist ja eben auch das große
thema testpflicht geht das an schulen zu
sagen
die kultusministerin von brandenburg
ernst hat eben glasklar gesagt wer eben
sich nicht testen lassen will oder den
test nicht macht der kann eben auch
nicht in der schulgebäude rein
die testpflicht ist ja heutzutage ist
der test ja nicht mehr so invasiv muss
man ja nicht unbedingt mehr sich
schmerzen zufügen deswegen ist dieser
eingriff in die körperliche integrität
jetzt deutlich geringer wir haben eine
gerechte gestaltung in bayern die gesagt
hat es schlicht in pflegeheim ist
unzulässig weil es eben auch so massiv
eingreift jetzt gibt es eine
entscheidung vom oberverwaltungsgericht
in sachsen die sagt test schlecht geht
in ordnung obwohl natürlich die
stigmatisierung da ist wenn ich jetzt in
der schule ein kind habe und das muss er
den crooner test machen und dann sagen
die andere hh der hat corona das ist
natürlich wirklich auch ein eingriff in
die persönlichkeitsrechte aber muss eben
abgewogen werden
mit der gesundheits mit dem
schutzauftrag des staates für gesundheit
sodass man hier durchaus meine ich einen
vorwand für die tests schlecht sehen
wird und was jetzt die frage angeht ob
der bund die schule geschichte regen
kann es natürlich wirklich eine
querschnitts geschichte infektionsschutz
ist eigentlich originäre zuständigkeit
des bundes schule aber eben der länder
also da könnte man streiten darüber muss
der bundesrat zustimmen oder kann er nur
einspurig verzögern kann man das ganze
auf jeden fall wenn er denn will
jetzt kommt in dem zusammenhang
interessante frage an sie beide von
unserem user ekrem halten könnte wenn
die minister das blockieren er meint
wahrscheinlich damit möglicherweise
jetzt im bundesrat wenn das ganze
blockiert wird könnte dann die
bundesregierung den ausnahmezustand
ausrufen und dann sozusagen alleine
regieren
herr lauterbach
also wir haben tatsächlich im
infektionsschutzgesetz war rechte so
dass das zur not tatsächlich ging
rechtlich also dinge dass wir könnten
prinzip also hier in einer solchen
situation könnten wir sehr weit
reichende
so könnte sehr weitreichende gesetze
machen aber ich glaube dass das wie
gesagt überhaupt keine rolle spielt das
wird nicht so sagen außer werden im
lichte der stark ansteigenden fallzahlen
werden die in der nächsten woche sich da
zusammen draußen wird das funktionieren
ich bin leider zeitlich etwas nach
hinten also gebunden
ich wollte aber noch etwas sagen zu dem
was eben vorgetragen wurde also die
verhältnismäßigkeit der festwägen nicht
schulen also ich glaube wir haben jetzt
eine ganze zeit haben den fehler gemacht
dass wir gesagt haben aus die kinder
wieder getestet werden
die testen wir nur damit die infektion
nicht weitergeben und lehre und
erwachsenen gefährden
die kinder die da getestet werden die
schützen wir auch selbst die schützen
wir selbst indem sie relativ früh dann
auch was so isoliert werden können so
dass die krankheit besser beobachtet
werden kann das ist der bessere die
karkasse selbst durchkommen und ich
schützen die anderen kinder schützen
noch die kinder untereinander und unter
diesen umständen also wenn man von den
gravierenden konsequenzen von
verschleppten fällen ihren schuhen
ausgeht ist aus meiner sicht eine solche
diskussion auch das testen da
stigmatisierend wird oder nicht also das
ist so wenn das so ist dann muss hat
sich da auf rechnung getragen werden wie
auch psychologen zuarbeit man muss das
einsprechen nahen geebnet werden
aber der also sozusagen das kranke kind
in die schule zu lassen damit es nicht
als stigmatisierend also in der schule
getestet werden muss das ist aus meiner
sicht eine abwegige abwägen abwägung
also eher die diskussion wie man das
geschickt macht da gibt's ja
unterschiedliche sachen die schon
ausprobiert werden in berlin werden die
tests den eltern mitgegeben also zu
hause wird getestet das hat dann
vielleicht noch den vorteil dass man
nicht mit dem bus und der bahn ein
infiziertes kind auf dem weg zur schule
hat da kann man darüber diskutieren herr
lauterbach wir danken ihnen ganz ganz
ganz ganz herzlich und werden ja
gemeinsam sie werden das auch mit
interesse tun dann schauen wie es
nächste woche weitergeht
wie das infektionsschutzgesetz dann im
detail aussehen wird was das
bundeskabinett beschließen will
und was der bundestag eventuell der
bundesrat dann eben dazu sagt ganz ganz
herzlichen dank für die zeit und alles
gute ich danke ihnen
ja felix da sind viele sachen die
natürlich jetzt auch erstmal entschieden
werden müssen
dabei hat es gesagt wie wird das ganze
im detail aussehen heute ist einiges
eben sozusagen durchgesickert was auf
dem tisch liegt aber wir haben die
erfahrung in der vergangenheit ja auch
gemacht
vieles ist auf dem tisch wenn ich hier
an beschlüsse denke vom dritten drittel
die vom kanzleramt gekommen sind und was
ist am ende verabschiedet worden und was
es verabschiedet worden was es am ende
umgesetzt worden also müssen wir da ein
bisschen schauen
ich danke dir aber auch ganz herzlich
wir werden dann sozusagen ja auch
gemeinsam schauen was die gerichte am
ende machen ob jemand eben hingeht und
klagt was gerichte dann machen und
insofern werden wir das ganze weiter
begleiten wir danken ganz herzlich für
ihr interesse
das war unser zdf heute live zur frage
ob es sozusagen einen machtwechsel gibt
einen strategiewechsel mitten in der
dritten welle vielen dank für ihr
interesse